hitting a shot is up the street a cop
got shot
I really have a hard time believing the
individual responsible as part of a
protest every night I've been out here
it's been really peaceful nonviolent and
I hope that that is the trend the call
definitely think there's quite a bit
more violence Tommy you think the time I
don't all right back well things are
going to tell us out dealers are you
have to get rid of our conservative
performance I give it all the cops I
thought a lot of problems there is a
chance there will be more violence if
peoples
tensions are still raised if everyone
came together as a whole lay aside their
differences in their titles of who they
are
recognize that they're people